so in autism I collaborate with some
folks at Cold Spring Harbor lab where
we're participating in a project through
the that's been sponsored by the Simons
Foundation and the idea there is is over
the last several decades different
hospitals around the u.s. have been
identifying families where one kid will
have autism their sibling does not and
have been collecting from those people
blood samples of the autistic child
their sibling and also their parents so
then the questions tend to be well what
is it about these autistic kids in terms
of their genome that is special or
changed or different relative to their
parents relative to their siblings that
either predisposed or perhaps even
caused the disorder there's been a lot
of interest there's been a lot of study
about this there's there's a lot of
uncertainty about this and really it's
been the growth of DNA sequencing
technology is that it's made as possible
to finally really drill down into the
genome to see what exactly is special
about kids with autism so from through
some early studies there was a lot of
evidence that so-called de novo
mutations were at least partially
responsible for autism so a de novo
mutation is most of your genome is is is
a combination of your parents genome so
it's after your mom plus half your dad
put together forms you but a very very
small number of changes are so-called de
novo meaning that there will be
spontaneous changes in the genome there
have been some earlier work through Mike
wigglers labs and and others that saw
that there were large-scale it's called
copy number changes were associated with
autism or segments of the genome would
either be duplicated or segments of the
genome would be deleted and lost and
kids with autism now through improved
sequencing technology we can drill down
and we can look and see well what are
the specific bases that are being
deleted or amplified what are the
specific mutations it just gives us
incredible power to be able to identify
these changes we're still relatively
early in the project so far we've
sequence about three hundred such
families the full project will be about
3,000 families and the hope there is to
be able to identify the patterns that
that that lead to the disease